[Music]
on this Thursday night trouble in space
this is the issue that's under
discussion the shocking leak at the
International Space Station and what it
could mean for those on board could
really put the astronauts life in danger
the official plea for patients as
millions of Canadians brace for a winter
Wallop British nurses walk off the job
this government has turned its back on
nursing why their historic strike is
being watched closely on both sides of
the pond
plus the push for high tech in a manual
industry have 3D printing could help
solve Canada's housing crunch
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight for a Nasser good
evening and thank you for joining us we
begin with a routine Space Walk that was
canceled just as it was about to start
flight controllers on the ground
discovered a leak coming from the soyuz
spacecraft which is docked to the
International Space Station Now The
Voyage to space is dangerous in itself
rocketing 1600 kilometers per hour just
to get to the space station and then
performing precise tasks in zero gravity
it's not a job for the faint of heart
but it just got a lot harder in our top
story tonight Eric Sorensen looks at
whether this leak poses any risk to the
crew and if the spacecraft can be fixed
flight speed and liftoff the soyuz
spacecraft lifted off almost three
months ago and like so many trips to the
International Space Station went off
without a hitch it's being docked at the
ISS ever since
but just as two Russian crew members
were about to take a spacewalk this
happened a leak apparently coolant
spewing into space NASA was watching and
talking to Russian mission control the
issue that's under discussion right now
as to what may be causing this stream of
particles that appears to be coming
from the area
of the instrumentation and propulsion
module of the soyuz ms-22 Canadian Chris
Hadfield has flown on a soyuz spacecraft
and commanded the space station he
posted a blunt assessment serious
coolant leak from the Russian soyuz crew
capsule docked at the space station not
good lots of fast decision making going
on Russian officials believe a
micrometeorite may have punctured the
soyuz M22 but the crew is believed safe
for now and we do have a confirmed soft
capture Precision Maneuvers like this
cargo docking just two weeks ago and
pristine images that we often take for
granted belie the very real hazards for
humans in space there's a ton of
micrometeorites that are just you know
flying around all the time space junk
radiation and everything that could
really put the astronauts life in danger
foreign in October a SpaceX launch
brought four other astronauts to the
space station so right now there are
seven crew members up there the question
is can the soyuz be fixed it will
definitely not take a risk if they're
not 100 sure about its safety so they're
working on figuring out if it's safe
enough to use it to come back to earth
in the weeks ahead the leak may require
another soyuz mostly empty to be sent up
on a rescue mission for now at the
International Space Station one of two
docked spacecraft is out of commission
and the other isn't big enough to bring
home all seven crew members at one time
Eric Sorensen Global News Toronto
back on Earth and here at home winter
has set in for many Canadians and it
could be a treacherous weekend in
eastern parts of the country people are
digging out from their first big
snowfall as another nasty storm takes
aim at Ontario and Quebec and as the icy
conditions take hold there are growing
questions around critical resources and
whether they'll be ready to tackle the
tough winter ahead Ross Lord reports
after the first snowstorm of the Season
some of the 30 plus centimeters in Morel
Pei has melted away made a lot of work
the next day moving it the heavy wet
snow that remains is easier for
residents to take as long as their roads
have been cleared
the plot they do hit the highways pretty
quickly some Canadian cities are
straining to stay on top of snow removal
labor shortages that intensify during
the pandemic now include plow operators
the city of St John New Brunswick
suggests plow parts and drivers are both
an increasing concern the challenge we
have is the the ability to to ramp up
according to a snowstorm we just don't
have that so the redundancies aren't
there in Nova Scotia high winds and
heavy snowfall knocked out power to
thousands of people and with winter just
beginning getting rid of all that snow
means closing a labor Gap the Nova
Scotia Department of Public Works admits
more operators are needed but says we're
confident that we'll continue to meet
our level of service standards
in Canada's largest city Toronto there
are also fewer plow operators as
commuters navigate a combination of rain
freezing rain and snow Toronto
transportation services says a new zone
system doesn't require as many plow
drivers it's the nature of how we
organize and structured the contracts so
it is a little bit less than it was last
time I hired a 123 new staff in November
to help with our in-house service
execution and the contractors do have
sufficiently Labor to provide the
services another critical Public Service
under pressure in these uncertain times
Ross Lord Global News
several winter weather alerts are in
effect for southern parts of Ontario and
Quebec heavy snow is the biggest threat
Global News meteorologist Ross Hull is
north of Toronto tracking the storm Ross
it looks like it's really coming down
around you
by Pharaoh well as you can see very
heavy wet snow where I am just north of
Toronto it has been affecting the
evening commute now it took some time
for the snow to build up in this part of
the province because it was wet snow
initially but those Southeast winds are
certainly picking up and making travel
difficult this is a massive system it
has been impacting areas of Southern
Manitoba there's been severe weather in
the Southeast U.S with this system and
basically there's been another system
Branch off from it and it's the snow
from that system that is impacting
Southern Ontario's Southwestern Quebec
heading into Friday morning through the
night on Thursday into Friday morning
and likely into Saturday heaviest
amounts will likely be around Ottawa
where there's the potential for 15 to 25
centimeters of snow Montreal could see
15 plus for that morning commute Ottawa
will be impacted too and all of this
will be moving towards New Brunswick by
Saturday so definitely some messy winter
weather in place for millions of
Canadians tonight into Friday and likely
lasting into early Saturday pharah Ross
thanks for your coverage while the snow
is blowing on you Ross Hall in Markham
Ontario
and as Ross just mentioned the bad
weather hitting Canada came up from the
U.S where it's also taking a swipe at
the East Coast Minnesota and North
Dakota crews are working around the
clock there to clear roads and dig out
stranded vehicles in North Dakota Snow's
piling up and the visibility is poor
making roads treacherous
and that same storm is also behind a
string of deadly tornadoes in the
southern U.S residents are surveying the
damage and hard hit Louisiana at least
three people were killed the windows in
this Hospital were blown out and tens of
thousands of people are without power
across Six States
in Ottawa today the federal government
announced it will delay an expansion off
medical assistance in dying laws this
comes after a string of experts raised
concern that the proper safeguards
aren't in place yet to expand the
eligibility criteria the chair of the
provincial Health Minister says it's the
right decision as Ottawa hasn't done a
good job in providing the necessary
guidance
I want to assure Canadians that it isn't
just the case that you can walk off the
street and seek made if you're if you're
feeling depressed of course it's the
right decision to do as they've done
but the real challenge will be for the
provinces and we're still waiting for
them to give important guidance and
decision about a change in the law that
they made
the Liberals are going to need to amend
the legislation to extend the ban and
will seek support from other parties
when Parliament resumes in January
Alberta is pushing back against the
federal government on regulating
firearms in the province Justice
Minister Tyler shandrow says provincial
Crown prosecutors will decide whether or
not to pursue charges under the federal
firearms act in the new year
well they're trying to remove legal
firearms ownership and they're targeting
Canadians who have lawfully obtained
purchased their firearms rather than
working on measures that would improve
safety in our communities
the move reflects Alberta's concern over
a federal ban on a range of firearms
that was implemented in 2020. Chandra
says The Province does not consider it
to be in the public interest to go after
law-abiding owners of Legally acquired
banned weapons
the federal government will cover the
cost of doing a feasibility study to
search a Winnipeg landfill where the
remains of two First Nations women are
believed to be buried Mark Miller
Canada's crowned indigenous relations
Minister says Ottawa will work with the
Winnipeg Police and the province of
Manitoba to make sure the coordinated
approach is sensitive to the needs of
the victims families
it's a site that is full of a number of
complexities and and we're glad to
deploy the resources the Federal
Government Can including Financial
Resources to help with with uh with what
will be a feasibility study and we'll
set the stages for the next
conversations that we'll have with the
families foremost in in the search for
foreclosure
police are under increasing pressure to
search the landfill but have said a
search would not be feasible police
think the bodies of Morgan Harris and
Mercedes Myron have been at the site
since May buried under at least 12
meters of densely compacted waste the
women are believed to be the victims
often alleged serial killer
a Quebec judges ruled Canadian Pacific
Railway is not liable in the Lac Meg
antique Railway disaster that killed 47
people the company has long maintained
it bored no responsibility for the
disaster because the train was not
operated by CP employees or traveling on
CP tracks in the very early morning of
July 6 2013 the 73 car train owned by
the Montreal Maine and Atlantic Railway
and Karen crude oil rolled down a hill
into the town of lake magentique and
exploded igniting a huge fire prime
minister Justin Trudeau says Canada's
electronic spy agency is keeping a close
eye on social media giant Tick Tock as
calls grow for Ottawa to ban the popular
chinese-owned app
I think people are obviously watching
very carefully there's a range of ways
that we're active in keeping Canadians
safe the communication security
establishment CSC is one of the best
cyber security agencies in the world and
they're watching very carefully
Trudeau's comments come on the heels of
U.S lawmakers introducing a bill aimed
at Banning Tick Tock the proposed
legislation there would block all
transactions from any social media
company that's in or under the influence
of China Russia or what it calls other
foreign countries of concern the growing
fears about potential Chinese government
influence have sparked several Nations
to propose a ban of tick-tock the
Beijing based app which reaches more
than one billion users globally insists
the fears are unfounded and is calling
the measures politically motivated
as housing prices keep getting higher in
this country federal agencies are
sticking to their policies to protect
the market the office of the
superintendent of financial institutions
announced today that it's keeping its
mortgage stress test in place
in this situation that we're in today it
makes sense for Canada to continue with
our tradition of being careful being
thoughtful being prudent
earlier this month the Bank of Canada
raised its Benchmark rate to 4.25
percent that's the highest it's been
since 2008 and in turn Canada's biggest
banks raised their prime lending rate to
nearly six and a half percent the stress
test as well as other mortgage standards
will be reviewed in January but are
expected to remain in place
could Innovation help solve our housing
crisis coming up the high-tech tool
looking to deliver big changes in
Canadian Construction Plus British
nurses take to the streets as their
labor fight escalates
[Music]
a historic Day in the United Kingdom
tens of thousands of nurses in England
Wales and Northern Ireland walked off
the job the first such strike in more
than 100 years and it's happening at the
busiest time of year for hospitals there
nurses say they're burnt out from the
pandemic and chronically underpaid but
as Europe bureau chief Crystal gomancing
Reports it's not just in the UK where
Healthcare Heroes feel like they're
still not getting the respect they
deserve
[Music]
loud emotional and tired nurses in
England Wales and Northern Ireland are
putting it all out on the line in a e
where I work you know we regularly have
people queuing out the door from 9am and
it doesn't stop until after midnight
because there's so much need and demand
out there and we don't have enough
resource or service to to provide care
for them all
part of the issue according to members
of the Royal College of nurses Union is
that people can't afford to be nurses
the job stress is immeasurable and wages
haven't kept up with inflation we're
here because this government has turned
its back on on nursing when they turn
their back in nursing they've turned
their back on patients and they've
turned their back on the NHS
the union wants a 19 increase the
government offered 4.75 inflation is
more than double that so nurses say
they'll end up with nothing being out on
the picket line is a bitter pill for
nurses especially these ones here at St
Thomas's hospital this is where former
prime minister Boris Johnson was cared
for after he contracted covet 19. back
then the government called nurses
national heroes
had some family come visit you Rishi
sunak the current prime minister got an
earful on the issue back in October you
don't pay them all well we are trying we
are a nutshell you need to try harder
right I will take that away asking for a
19 pay rise way above what most viewers
themselves are receiving is not
affordable given the many of their
economic pressures that we Face
public support for nurses remains high
but the government hasn't budged workers
everywhere including Canada are running
out of steam this demonstration linked
to wages took place in Toronto on Monday
with covid and other serious respiratory
infections packing clinics and hospitals
many aren't sure they can keep going
well I do you see the struggles and it
is real
another 12-hour walkout is planned for
next week Crystal gavancing Global News
London
[Music]
Food For Thought ahead why protecting
biodiversity is critical to keeping your
kitchen cabinets full
[Music]
in Montreal World delegates are in the
final days of negotiations at the UN
biodiversity Summit also known as cop15
but it's not looking great more than 60
countries walked off in protest on
Wednesday over concerns wealthier
Nations funding pledges were too small
and vague eventually talks resumed but
Deal or No Deal human driven activity
like climate change still threatens a
vast number of plant and animal species
and as Sharia Israel explains it's also
disrupting our food supply while driving
up prices
inflation keeps spoiling dinner plans by
leaving Shoppers with fewer and fewer
options I went to buy some lamb lately
and it was 70 dollars a kilo and and I
just left it there
food prices are climbing at the fastest
rate in four decades I had a dinner
party on Saturday night and it cost me
probably double what it would have
normally cost me the line connects from
the kitchen table to the negotiating
table delegates in Montreal are trying
to come up with a plan to protect nature
and the food it provides Food Systems is
contributing Wilfred Laurier University
Professor Allison Blake Palmer is at the
summit biodiversity is linked to food
prices because the more we rely on a few
crops the more volatile and precarious
our food system is take the insects that
pollinate crops their numbers are
dwindling which cost the agriculture
industry an estimated
577 billion dollars a year
while climate change drives up prices so
can efforts to fight it we put a price
on carbon which most experts would say
is a is kind of a required tool to to
help us to confront climate change but
it does have an inflationary impact on
oil and gas and agriculture is really
dominated by by it really is dependent
on on oil and gas while agriculture is a
major source of pollution there are
Canadian Farmers finding Sustainable
Solutions to tackle climate change and
inflation at this time of year they're
like Stuart Oak runs an organic farm
south of Ottawa and grows more than 40
kinds of vegetables
he believes preserving the world's
biodiversity starts with local
initiatives people need to understand
the value and and having food that's
close to home and and of course some of
the supply chain and food shortages we
saw earlier in the pandemic was a really
good example
finding new approaches from the
community to the global stage to protect
what we eat teriya isri Global News
North Augusta Ontario
automation Nation next how machines and
Robotics could help solve Canada's
housing crisis
foreign
automation to solve a lot of things
these days chores work even Supply
chains so could it solve the housing
crisis the shortage of affordable
housing in Canada is just getting worse
but Innovations like 3D printing could
be a way to build more homes quicker
easier and even greener in part three of
our automation Nation series and gaviola
explores some potential Construction
Solutions
foreign build faster and eventually
build way cheaper that is the value
proposition from kingston-based nidus 3D
there's going to be a need for for sort
of human oversight of that for a very
long time still humans are involved in
every step when it comes to 3D printing
homes but machines do the heavy lifting
the Forefront of 3D construction
printing is China and they're working on
aspects of this technology that I don't
think we even really know about yet and
so I think we should be pursuing this
innovate or get left behind Automation
and Robotics are a part of the solution
for an industry struggling to find
enough workers to keep up with a frenzy
demand for more homes especially in
Ontario Alberta and BC a fifth of the
current construction Workforce is set to
retire in the coming decade during covid
the construction industry in general
lost almost 60 000 workers to due to
early retirement and so you know that's
not only a lot of workers that we lost
but that's a lot of experience that we
lost as well how does our our housing
Supply shortage rank globally well
Canada has the lowest number of housing
units per capita of all the G7 countries
at our current pace of construction
housing stock is projected to increase
by 19 million units by 2030. to restore
affordability an estimated additional
three and a half million affordable
housing units are needed by 2030 for a
total of 22 million housing units it's
not a question of taking jobs away but
actually creating capacity to build the
kind of numbers of homes that we're
talking about from building homes and
mapping them out automation Robotics and
new innovation all part of the solution
so is highlighting the benefits of a
career in construction I think we have
to make construction cool again I think
we got to get kids interested in going
into the trades part of the draw using
the latest and greatest technology to
build homes that are Greener we've had a
lot of great responses from the classes
and the children we've shown the
technology to so far so hopefully that
points to the Future effectively
tackling Canada's housing crisis
involves accelerating the path for new
tech and new careers and gaviola Global
News Toronto
and that's global national for this
Thursday I'm Farah Naser tonight's here
Canada is the Holiday Lights of fourth
degree you've been land and Labrador
thank you for watching hope to see you
again here tomorrow good night
[Music]